on Scotty reddit you know her
a'dreea the strategic alliance Scott is
a professor at UT Austin
he could be director of the National
Science Foundation it could be white
house science advisor now the problem
with that one is that there has to be
someone in the White House to advise
decided on his own what's really
important and that is to prove Gil
collide to talk about random circuit
sampling so thank you Greg for that a a
unique introduction so yeah it is great
to be here as always and I would indeed
much much rather be here than it does
it's having experience than both and
iiiiii did pick up a call there and I
apologize if I lose my voice but
fortunately it's a small room so now now
I do feel a little sheepish because Adam
already did such a spectacular job this
morning sort of explaining the basic
theory of quantum supremacy experiments
that you know I'm sort of reduced to you
know providing some comic relief to go
afterward but you know no it's actually
very useful for me because I will build
directly on what he talked about and so
so well so what I think I'll do is I'll
just I'll pick up you know literally
right where he left off talking about
the the actual task that Google applied
in its recent experiment this are linear
cross-entropy benchmark
and what do we know about the classical
hardness of spoofing that benchmark you
know a long story short not not not as
much as we would like
although not not a completely nothing
either and and then what I want to do is
this sort of tell you what are some of
my favorite open problems and future
research directions about quantum
supremacy because you know I think that
you know this is not like you know one
shot you know Google did it and then
we're all finished right we are now at
the very beginning of an era of 50 to
let's say 200 or 300 qubit noisy quantum
computers that look like they will
mostly be good for various sampling
tasks and so you know it would behoove
us to figure out well you know what what
sampling tasks are out there you know
are there any that are actually useful
to anyone that people care about how
sure are we that they're hard for
classical computers to simulate how do
we verify their results okay and you
know I'm gonna try to convince you in
this talk that even at the purely
theoretical level you know there are
there there there there is more open
than closed about about all of those
questions okay and and you know just to
show you what what what some of my
personal favorite directions are so okay
so let's let's go back to the basic
setting of random circuit sampling that
Adam talked about and you know so we
have a verifier that generates quantum
circuits from some probability
distribution in the case of googles
experiment these are 2-dimensional you
know nearest neighbor circuits on on a
grid you know with some particular gate
set which you know happens to be
computationally universal but in
and of course we could attach numbers to
it in their experiment you know n the
number of qubits was 53 the number of
layers of gates in there their hardest
circuits that they were able to do and
still extract the signal was about 20
you know depth of 20 so you're talking
about on the order of 1,000 gates maybe
and so they generate the circuit
randomly you know now you might you know
other the question came up this morning
you might already be worried that in the
experiment that's been done Google was
both the verifier and the prover that
could certainly be a you know addressed
in in the future and that's that's
that's just like a one tiny example of
the many many things that remain to be
done here okay but let's you know let's
let's just a trust for now that they you
know they did generate a circuit in the
way that they said then basically what
happens is that that circuit is sent
over to the quantum computer or more
literally the you know a classical
computer programs in the circuit by
control wires that go into the dilution
refrigerator loads the circuit onto it
this is my stylized quantum computer you
know forgive my poor heart work then the
quantum computer is challenged to
quickly generate samples from the output
probability distribution corresponding
to that circuit okay and this is some
distribution over and bit strings you
know in which which is not a uniform
distribution some of the strings are
likelier than others you know even
though all of them in general are
exponentially unlikely right but you
know some have probability like 2 over 2
to the N others only 1 over 2 to the N
or less and and and those little
non-uniformities are precisely what we
are looking for ok yeah the whole point
of the experiment is going to be to
whether the samples that are generated
are preferentially clustered among the
ones that were predicted to have the
higher probabilities okay the the
conjecture being that that task
generating samples like that is
something that should be hard for a
classical computer and you know we will
of course have to come back to the
evidence for that okay so so as Adam
discussed the test that Google ended up
applying is you know one of the simplest
ones that you could possibly write down
you know it's code they call it at the
linear xeb linear cross entropy
benchmark and all you do with this test
is that you take all of the samples that
are that were generated by the quantum
computer so each of these s 1 s 2 and so
forth is each an n bit string in this
case a 53 bit string ok K is just the
number of samples so just to give you a
sense a K is going to be tiny compare it
to 2 to the n okay so you will see a
number of samples that is sort of not
nearly enough to fully characterize this
distribution we simply don't have enough
time for that but the number of samples
does have to be large enough that you
can do valid statistics on it okay and
so this okay the number of samples will
be parsh partly set by then the amount
of noise in the device and a good rule
of thumb is that if the fidelity of the
quantum computer is epsilon so meaning
you know for sampling from let's say
epsilon times the distribution that we
really want plus 1 minus epsilon times
the uniform distribution or something
like that then the number of samples
that we're going to whine is going to
scale roughly like 1 over epsilon
squared ok and that's just a basic
matter of statistics that you know in
order for us to even detect information
theoretically that this signal was there
gonna need this many samples and and and
and I should add by the way that the the
actual distribution you know we could
sir is not going to be exactly like this
or we certainly don't know it to be like
this and in our hardness arguments we
will not be relying on the assumption
that the distribution is has this form
this is just a heuristic okay so in the
case of Google's experiment epsilon is
the you know meaning the fidelity of the
device was about point zero zero two
right about one in five hundred and so
the K that they took with several
million okay that sounds like a lot but
the good news is that once the circuit
is loaded onto the chip then each sample
each s sub I can be taken in about forty
microseconds it means you know to sort
of initialize the circuit you know get
sort of get the chip ready to apply this
circuit over and over again
okay so there's some startup costs to
doing that which is you know maybe like
you know I don't know a hundreth or a
tenth of a second or something like that
okay but then once it's loaded yeah that
once it's once it's pre loaded then each
each each of these samples is only about
forty microseconds well we we are not
assuming that they are independent you
know in the sort of honest case we are
hoping that they're independent but even
if they are not entirely independent you
know our hardness arguments will not
depend on the assumption that they were
itself but it could be in some sense
loaded into the equipment yeah it's it's
loaded into the control system yeah
okay
so yeah and you know and and and and and
the very fact that I am you know quoting
you these numbers I think is like a sign
of how our field has evolved you know
and that you know I think if I were
giving this talk ten years ago I would
have said well you know each each sample
is you know is is I love wine or you
know right rather you know I would be or
D is the depth and just left it there
okay but yeah okay so so so so now with
the linear cross entropy benchmark what
you're going to do is you're going to
just with your classical computer
calculate the sort of ideal probability
for each of the samples si by that you
saw and then you're just going to sum
them all up and that we're gonna
consider the test to have accepted you
know to have to we're gonna consider the
quantum computer to have passed the test
if and only if this sum exceeds some
threshold okay so you know intuitively
you know the better the experiment the
larger should be this sum right because
we should be you know preferentially
fight be finding the the outputs that
we're supposed to have larger
probabilities right that's kind of what
the quantum computer is supposed to do
so you know we can now just just think
about well what what values of this sum
would we expect and so so let's first
consider well if we just had a classical
computer that was just generating the S
sub i's uniformly at random you know
just completely ignoring the circuits C
then what value would we get well you
know each probability in expectation is
of course 2 to the minus n you know some
are a little large or some a little
smaller but if I just add up K random
ones then I would expect to get about K
over 2 to the N here which means I'm
gonna call that a value of B equals one
okay now we can next ask what if we had
an ideal quantum computer with no noise
whatsoever and then this is just simply
a calculation that you can do
where you use the fact that if I take a
random sequence of gates random circuit
it so so you know if it's a small random
circuit it will not produce a horror and
instated are nearly enough degrees of
freedom and a small circuit to do that
but it will produce a state that for
most purposes behaves as if it were a
hard random state ok and in a few cases
this can even now be analytically proven
I got a dimension the results of Arum
Harrow and see Mara bond for example and
even in in the cases where it hasn't
been proven it is a known to be true by
means of MATLAB and so so so so so
assuming that the amplitudes are you
know like independent complex Gaussian
variables which is you know what they
will be in a sort of fully scrambled you
know a scrambled up random looking
quantum state now the key point is that
well so you know if I draw a bunch of
gap complex gaussians of being 0 well
you know they'll have slightly different
distances from the origin some will be a
little larger and other smaller in
magnitude and there's a beautiful
mathematical fact that if you take the
squared absolute value of a just a
complex Gaussian in order to get a
probability then this gives you
precisely an exponentially distributed
random variable ok so the probabilities
you know in this distribution ID or we
could call it V sub C or our X are going
to be exponentially distributed random
variables right they have a mean of 2 to
the minus n but you know they can they
can be larger or smaller ok so like that
and you know by the way this is only
true of amplitudes or complex numbers
if they were reals if they were kotor
nians it would not work out exactly this
way ok so but now using the fact that
the probabilities are sort of expert
actually distributed one can calculate
will you just do an integral for sort of
what is the expectation of this sum if I
actually sampled the S sub i's from DC
if I you know sampled them with an ideal
quantum computer and the answer turns
out to be that I would achieve this
inequality with B be equal to two okay
it's just so much so the quantum value
is sort of exactly twice the classical
value the random sampling value now so
so now you know what what I really like
about this is that in some sense we have
a computational complexity analog of the
Bell inequality right so you know the
the Bell inequality you know said here's
an experiment you can do here is you
know some inequality that we expect that
in any classical picture of the world
will be satisfied and then here is what
the prediction of quantum mechanics and
it violates that inequality right by
some constant amount okay and now when
we do the experiment for real we almost
certainly will not achieve the predicted
quantum value okay because the noise in
our experiment is going to lower the the
you know the R value back down toward
the classical one but as long as we can
achieve a value that is bounded above
the classical value then that is enough
to rule out a classical explanation for
this experiment okay and that is exactly
what happened in the Google supremacy
experiment so they they say that they
they measured you know a value of B
equals about one point zero zero two
okay and you know so you'll notice that
this is quite far from the ideal to but
they were able to take enough samples to
you know show that they were bounded
above one okay and so now you know the
the question that interests us is well
what are we to make of that
you know how hard is it to serve spoof
this classically right and you know even
if we agreed that it seems kind of hard
to classically spoof you know B equals
- well couldn't there be some fast
classical method that would just get
slightly above one okay so we're going
to address that question yeah your
analogy to the Bell yes
I mean classically you're doing the
right thing when you compare those two
right so we don't have well of course we
don't know what is the best classical
algorithm so you know I mean that that
is a question that we're gonna have to
address I mean what in the case of you
know the Bell inequality was a theorem
that we could prove you know here is
going to rely on some unproved
complexity conjecture that is just the
nature of the beast okay yeah yeah yeah
yeah we equals 1 is what you would get
with classical random sampling we now
need to explicitly address the obvious
question of is there a classical
algorithm that would get better than B
equals 1 okay so okay well you know of
course we don't know right like if we
suppose that P equals P space for
example then surely there would be such
an algorithm right which is enough to
demonstrate that any argument we give
will have to depend on some unproved
complexity assumption and there is no
possible way around that no way of
talking around it and okay anything okay
but there but you know there's a
question of well what assumption right
now
it would be wonderful if you know we
could say well provided the polynomial
hierarchy does not collapse or something
like that then you know no classical
algorithm can beat B equals 1
unfortunately we do not know how to do
that ok and you know and this is this is
maybe you know the first of the open
problems or research directions that I
will raise right get better evidence for
the hardness of spoofing the
verification procedures in these quantum
supremacy experiments ok we you know as
Adam mentioned it is a major open
problem even just to show that
approximate sampling or you know
sampling a distribution that is closed
in variation distance to the target
distribution that if a classical
computer could do that then the
polynomial hierarchy would collapse
right and here where we're you know I'm
asking for something more stringent than
that because I want to rule we want to
rule out any classical algorithm that's
that would spoof this linear cross
entropy benchmark even if that that
algorithm might work in a completely
different way than just sampling from
the target distribution right you could
imagine a classical algorithm that
somehow just zeroes in on the S sub i's
that maximize this you know dis score
right and that would you know do a
terrible job of sampling from the target
distribution but it would do great at
passing this test right we want to say
that even an algorithm like that you
know if if it existed and was fast on a
classical computer that that would have
some unlikely complexity consequence ok
now let me mention what Sam gone and I
were able to do very recently ok so this
was sort of an adaptation of some
earlier work that we G Chen and I did
and Sam gun isn't an undergrad at UT and
he and I just care gave a hardness
reduction
to serve specific to the linear
cross-entropy test that Google actually
applied and so so here here's what we
can say okay
let's say that you are given as input a
random quantum circuit see you know from
some ensemble like Google's okay and you
now have the task of estimating the
probability of a specific output string
I might as well say for simplicity the
final probability of the old zero string
so you know we start with the old 0
string we apply the circuit we measure
all our qubits in the zero one basis and
we just ask what is the probability of
getting back to the old 0 string ok so
so so of course this is a random
variable if you like as I vary over you
know the circuits see the expectation of
this random variable is what anyone well
it's you know there's there's two to the
N probabilities and by symmetry they all
have an expectation of 2 to the minus n
okay so so you know you might say the
trivial estimator for this probability
will just be the one that always outputs
2 to the minus n okay now
let me make a bold conjecture okay this
is this is this is where I'm gonna stick
my neck out okay
the conjecture will say that no
polynomial time classical algorithm is
able to achieve variance
it is like significantly better than
this than this trivial estimator so
basically in classical polynomial time
you know you get you can get almost no
insight into the probability of this
quantum random quantum circuit
outputting the old 0 string ok and and
and to be more precise the the variance
of any classical polynomial time
estimator I'm gonna conjecture that it
cannot even be like this much better
than the variance of the trivial
estimator like even it can't even be 1
over exponential in n and being a number
of qubits better than the trivial
estimator ok that's this is this is
where I'm sticking my neck out now just
to calibrate you ok it is possible to do
slightly slightly better than the
trivial estimator and a neat trick for
doing that is to use the Fineman path
integral right or you know what the I'll
call it that for physicists for the
computer scientists be the proof that
bqp is contained in PP ok these are two
different names for the same thing but I
could take the take a probability like
this one and I can write it as a sum of
exponentially many contributions ok and
I can then if I want to just estimate
this probability just you know very very
weakly you know
slightly better than chance I could
always just sample a few random terms in
that exponential sum right that gives me
this probability and what will I get
that way it's instructive to work it out
what I'll get is an estimator that does
this better that this much better than
the trivial estimator so like 1 over X
of M where m is the number of gates in
the circuit is it n if you're if you're
running gates in parallel ok I mean in
that case I would say it's the number of
it's the number of qubits times the
depth or something it's really just a
number of gates the total number of
gates in the circuit amplitudes that are
west and one from every single local
game um yeah yeah yeah but no but it's
really just the number of gates right
each gate like you multiply it out ok ok
so so it is actually important for us
that M is large compared to n right now
in the case of googles experiment let's
say n is 53 M is you know on the order
of a thousand ok the gap between those
two numbers actually matters and the end
and it was a further interesting point
you know this this type of conjecture
that we're making you know I think that
it is plausibly true for random quantum
circuits it is not true for boson
sampling ok it is not true for the IQ P
you know the Bremner joseon shepard
model okay in those models they were
sort of not an analogue of em there's
not a notion of a number of gates that
you know you just sort of sets your
hardness and that you can just very
independently of n ok so so so so we are
actually using that the fact that Google
you know built a chip that does you you
know in principle Universal quantum
computation it's not just a thing like
those on sampling okay so
so so so our whole conjecture is that
you know in classical polynomial time
yes you can get this bias in an
estimator of in of a probability but
you're not gonna get this kind of bias
okay now let me hand wave to you that if
you accept that conjecture then it
follows that there is no classical
polynomial time algorithm that can spoof
Google's linear cross-entropy benchmark
okay and even even get by getting B that
is slightly greater than one okay so the
the hardness reduction is like an
extremely simple one like once I've
posed the question I could just give
this as like a homework exercise for you
know people here but all we do is we say
well okay so so suppose that I had a
fast classical algorithm for spoofing
this cross-entropy benchmark right so
for generating samples with a large
value of this sum now I want to use it
somehow to get an estimator for for this
problem so the first thing I will do is
I will sort of have to hide I'll have to
sort of randomly permute my circuit in
such a way as to hide which final
amplitude I care about okay so I could
just like insert some random not gates
at the output layer in order to you know
the get a new circuit C prime where the
thing that I will care about is actually
the final amplitude of some other some
random other strings Z right and this is
just so you know might because of my
algorithm knew that I cared about the
old zero string then it could just
corrupt the estimate for that string
only okay I want it to be a random
string okay and and now
well what I'll do is I'll simply on my
my modified circuit C Prime
I will run my assumed fast a classical
algorithm for spoofing the linear cross
entropy benchmark okay that will
generate that algorithm when I run it
will generate some samples say s1 up to
SK and now I will simply ask the
question is Z the output that I care
about
among those samples are not okay and now
if Z is among those samples then that
gives me some very very weak statistical
evidence that maybe the this this
probability was a little bit larger than
average very you know if you know
conversely if Z was not among those
samples that gives me some very weak
evidence that a that probability maybe
was slightly smaller than average okay
this is you know a a really poor
estimation algorithm but it will achieve
if you calculate it it will achieve a
bias over the trivial estimator that
looks like this okay which is you know
good enough to refute that hardness
assumption okay so the the yeah are you
implicitly assuming that B is held
constant oh yes so so good so so so
there Thursday a trade-off here you know
with you know what I just said will
actually work for like any let's say any
constant B that is bounded above 1 and
it will even you know work for some you
know B that is like you know what 1 plus
1 over n you know things like that you
can even get closer to 1 here okay so so
so a couple points to make you know you
know you know we haven't done much but
what we've done is we've said that you
know there is nothing like super special
about spoofing this benchmark that
Google is applying right that that you
know if you could do that then actually
you would just get a handle into just
the general problem of estimating amp
output amplitudes in random
I'm circuits right so you know the two
things are connected and this and and
and indeed well I'm gonna discuss this
shortly but you know the actual examples
we've seen of algorithms for simulating
quantum supremacy experiments are not
tailored to spoofing these benchmarks
right they really do just you know
basically brute force the simulation of
the entire quantum circuit okay and so
we're giving some evidence that that is
that is inherent right that is that is a
necessary here okay the other point I
wanted to make is that the the noise in
the circuit you know in some sense the
only role that the noise played was to
decrease the value of B that was
achieved in the experiment okay and so
you know I'm stressing this because
people constantly object that well you
know how do you know you know even if
the noiseless experiment would be hard
to simulate don't you need to know the
exact details of the noise in google's
device you know and then couldn't you
know the specific you know nature of the
noise couldn't it screw you up and the
answer is no it doesn't right all that
the noise does is it decreases the B
value that you achieve it means that you
are violating this complexity theoretic
bail inequality by a smaller amount okay
but you know the hardness assumptions
that we have you know can talk about the
hardness of violating the complexity
theoretic Bell inequality by any amount
right and so you just have to violate it
by enough that you can detect that and
then you know further details of the
noise model you know just just do not
enter into the analysis okay so so so so
maybe you know the you know the the sort
of number one open problem you could say
is just get you know better evidence
than this for you know the classical
hardness of you know spoofing a quantum
supremacy experiment you know I would I
would love to know you know if we could
make a weaker conjecture than this
can one go in the other direction can
one
if if one could had a non-trivial
estimator here then one could spoof the
linear cross entropy benchmark I don't
know how to go in that direction I think
that's a really nice open problem but
now there's the eraser
of course it behooves us to look at the
opposite direction and say well could we
design better classical algorithms for
you know simulating random quantum
circuits or arbitrary quantum circuits
and
and and you know that seems like an
incredibly basic question you know that
would have been studied to death in the
90s or something so you know it was I
guess it was partly you know nice but
also partly disconcerting that you know
we when we looked at it in all over the
last few years we discovered new things
about this question and so so let me
just make a little table of some of the
the main algorithms that you might think
of for simulating a quantum circuit on a
classical computer and you know what
what what trade-offs do they have okay
so the most naive way to simulate a
quantum circuit classically would be
with what I'll call the Schrodinger
simulation which would simply write out
the entire wave function you know the
entire quantum state explicitly in
memory and then just keep updating it
okay so this is basically going to be
about 2 to the N time and also about 2
to the N memory okay and this would
correspond to let's say the proof that
bqp is contained in X exponential time
now to mention in in the response by IBM
to Google's paper where they said that
they could simulate Google supremacy
experiment and only a few days rather
than in 10,000 years you know using a
Samet at Oak Ridge National Lab which is
the largest supercomputer that currently
exists on earth they were they were just
talking about doing this completely
naive Schrodinger simulation and what
would MIT you know they haven't actually
done it it's not so easy to get time on
that machine okay but what what would
make it work in there there as according
to their paper is simply that some it
has 250 petabytes of hard disk space
okay and that is enough just barely
enough but that is enough to store 2 to
the 53 complex numbers which is about 9
quadrillion of them ok and then you just
do
you know brute-force roading or
simulations now a different approach one
that I already touched on would be the
Fineman simulation okay this is a much
much more a memory efficient solution
where you would just take the amplitude
that you the output amplitude that you
cared about and just write it as a sum
of exponentially many contributions and
then just sum up all those contributions
reusing the same memory for each one so
this uses only linear memory the time is
is the real issue here the time ends up
being exponential in M the number of
gates okay and you know even even Google
cannot do expo of a thousand so okay so
you know just staring at this you know
in an obvious question one could ask is
is there a way to interpolate and sort
of get the you know the best of both
worlds here that sort of surprisingly
was not really looked at but uh so Lee G
Chen and I a few years ago proposed a
hybrid algorithm which is really just if
you any of you know savages theorem and
complexity theory it's really basically
just that so the way it would work is
that you take a some amplitude that I
care about like from going from X to Y
and then I take my circuit C and I cut
it into two halves let's say two equal
sized pieces call them C 1 and C 2 and
then I can always take an amplitude like
this and I can rewrite it as XC 1 Z and
then Z C 2 y like that okay and then I
can so I can write an amplitude I care
about as a sum of products of amp
foods involving shallower circuits and
then I can recurse right I can
recursively evaluate each of these
amplitudes in the same way and if you
work out the recurrence relation what
you get is that this ends up using
linear memory and a time that grows like
D to the N where D is the depth of the
circuit is adapt to the number of qubits
so it's not you know it's not quite as
good as this okay but now that this is
actually now used in some of the
state-of-the-art simulations of quantum
circuits that IBM and Google and others
have done okay now what what else is out
there okay what other you know classical
algorithms are there for simulating
quantum circuits so you know another
major thing to pay attention to our
tensor network contraction methods these
typically work best when the depth of
the circuit is small okay so these also
have a dependence on on depth you know I
don't have time to go into them but it's
interesting that Google actually made
some engineering decisions you know in
building its sycamore chip such as you
know the choice of what what kinds of
two qubit gate they had purely in order
to try to evade quest tensor Network
simulations of their show yes oh I
suppose that you could view them in that
way yeah but you know there are there
are let's say there are yeah there are
tensor Network methods that sort of make
very explicit use of the spatial
locality in the load depth of the
circuit so that's that's matter what I
meant here but yeah this this is a
general you know framework that you
could you could also fit a lot these
other things
okay and and then I you know you so so
so that you know the fear is well well
what else could be out there you know
could there be algorithms that work for
you know just approximating the output
distribution of a random quantum circuit
even if they don't get it exactly and so
so here the very recent work by Knapp at
all which Adam also mentioned I found to
be extremely striking and so so what
they say is you know they don't have a
rigorous proof of this but uh
heuristically they can take a like two
dimensional spatially local quantum
circuit of constant depth and they can
approximately simulate it and what looks
like classical polynomial time
approximately simulate its output
distribution okay now this does not you
know conflict you know this this does
not refute the Google result because
it's it only works for very small depth
now what for for what depth exactly does
it work well they're not they're not
completely sure and you know the what
may be the most striking thing about
their result is that they say that there
is a phase transition in depth so once
you go beyond the phase transition then
their algorithm just completely fails
they don't know exactly where the phase
transition happens they say at any rate
you know for with qubits they expect it
to happen well before a depth of 20 okay
but you know this is you know in an
indication of you know well what else
might be out there that we have missed
so a bellas Barack has suggested to me
the conjecture which i think is very
plausible that there might be an
efficient classical algorithm that would
a spoof the linear cross entropy
benchmark you know in the case where
where the depth of the circuit is small
enough so it might achieve a value of B
that is for example one plus one over
exponential and in depth or something
like that maybe even one plus one over
double exponential in the depth okay but
you know one can even write down
algorithms that look like you know they
would plausibly achieve something like
this okay but there there remains a
great difficulty in analyzing them so so
I think that that such things are
certainly possible and they should be
investigated you know even if even even
even if you know the Google experiment
is already sort of you know outside of
the range where this is directly
relevant you know we should we should
know where the border is between Simula
bility and not okay
so now let me so that was my second
question
okay now my third question this is
something that that Adam also touched on
but I think you know one of the biggest
theoretical open problems for this area
right now is to figure out is there a
way of doing a quantum supremacy
experiment on a near-term device which
probably means some kind of sampling
based experiment but in such a way where
in order to verify the results with a
classical computer you do not have to do
a two to the end time classical
computation okay so we're where the
classical verification is is efficient
and you know this is I think this is an
immensely important problem okay because
you know right now you know a Google
actually did not directly verify its
hardest circuits it's you know 53 cubed
and depth 20 they you know relied on
extrapolations from easier cases you
know that you know you could find
plausible or not but I mean they they
went beyond you know they went all the
way up to the limit of what they could
simulate with their you know 1 million
core supercomputer that they had access
to you know running for like a month and
then they went beyond that point okay
now one of the immense ironies of the
IBM rebuttal paper is that if IBM can
indeed simulate Google's device using
the summit supercomputer then they
should also be able to verify Google's
hardest results you know and which would
be extremely useful for them right in a
you know in a regime where Google had
not had not known how to do that ok but
you are you know it's clear that with
these you know as long as the
verification is done by brute force you
know two to the N classical computation
then you're sort of limited to let's say
you know 50 queue
sixty cubits you're never gonna verify
something involving a hundred cubits or
two hundred cubits okay so I think that
this is a huge question and now let's
let's let's talk about what is known
about it so you know of course you know
if we if we if we had a full
fault-tolerant scalable quantum computer
then we have some excellent solutions to
this problem already
okay the classic you know you could say
you know one of the you know the the
golden oldie of you know quantum
supremacy experiments would be run
Shor's algorithm
you know factor a huge number and that
has the advantage that of course a
skeptic and just very very quickly check
the claim prime factors for itself
alternatively if you don't like
factoring we now know that you can take
any problem in bqp any quantum
computation whatsoever and under
suitable cryptographic assumptions there
is an interactive protocol where the
quantum computer will you know receive
challenges from a classical verifier
send back answers and where it will
actually prove that it executed the
quantum computation correctly this was
the breakthrough result of our Millah
mahadev okay unfortunately both of these
seem like they require a fault-tolerant
quantum computer or at least you know
something something approaching one
okay so we're you know we still have the
problem of what what are we going to do
let's say in the next five ten five to
ten years in the you know when what john
prescott calls the nist era the noisy
intermediate scale era and
so a couple things that I could mention
there was a beautiful proposal by Mick
Bremner and Dan Shepherd which which
involved their iqp model they're also
called the commuting Hamiltonians model
and they they gave a proposal for here
is a way that the verifier could
generate a random circuit but while they
do this they secretly you know remember
some some trapdoor information about
this circuit okay they remember
something about how they generated it so
let's say the verifier is generating a
circuit C sub K that depends on some
secret string K which the verifier will
keep okay now this goes to the quantum
computer the quantum computer now sends
back samples from the output
distribution of this C sub K you know s1
s2 and so forth and then the in their
protocol the classical computer would be
able to use its string K in order to
actually efficiently check these samples
ok the check you know are they clustered
in some secret way that depends on K
okay now the other way the way that this
worked was complicated it involved some
very specific error correcting codes I
never really understood it but I spent
10 years trying to get people more
interested in this in trying to you know
see is the secure is this not secure
this is exactly the kind of thing that
we would need and then a month ago I was
given giving a talk and you know
mentioning that people should really
spend more effort on this while I was
giving that talk actually a paper
appeared on the archive by Gregg kaha
new Hoku Meyer that name here at
Berkeley and this breaks the protocol so
we now know that this is insecure and so
now all the more so this is an open
problem design us some interactive
protocol for example for boson sampling
or four random circuit sampling design a
way to generate a a circuit you know
that can be applied by
your term device but in in such a way
that this circuit will have
exponentially many possible outputs but
you the person who generated the circuit
will know some secret that will let you
recognize the you know the outputs that
are coming as you know yes these are the
ones that I was looking for okay I think
that this is a wonderful challenge now
we did spend some time thinking about
this in the context of boson sampling
and so you might say that a dream you
know like like the the the if life you
know smiled on us maximally right then
you know maybe what you could do is with
with boson sampling for example you
could generate a linear optical network
where there is one particular output so
one particular you know a collection of
numbers of photons in each of the output
ports call it s where that output would
just have a really really large
probability by really really large I
mean like one over polynomial and N and
being a number of photons okay and you
magenta the linear optical network you
would know you would know s you would
generated along with knowledge of that
of this you know a enormous Li likely
output okay now now a classical person
who was just looking at the linear
optical network would have no clue what
s was okay you know it would just look
like a big mess to them but if you were
actually ran the experiment sent the
photons sent the N photons through the
linear optical network then a quantum
computer would be able to show that you
know yes it is getting s an appreciable
fraction of the time and in this way you
could verify that the boson sampling
experiment was doing the right thing
okay that would be great
unfortunately
there is a result which I did with the
mathematician Hawaii when in 2014 and
which was then built on by Berkowitz and
Devlin in 2016 and what it basically
shows is that this dream is unachievable
for boson sampling okay so what what
what we can show is that if you have a
if you have a matrix let's call it a and
it's norm is it most one so it can be
embedded into a unitary matrix and also
it's permanent is sort of appreciably
large like one over a polynomial and n a
is here in an N by n matrix complex
numbers then a it must be sort of highly
degenerate in some sense which one could
formalize by saying that most of the
rows of a will be dominated by a single
large entry okay or to put it
differently if I try to construct an
optical network that has this secretly
high probability output that output will
stick out like a sore thumb in my in my
description of the linear optical
network right the a classical person
will be able to find it you know very
easily okay so but now now this does not
rule out that some interactive protocol
could be done for boson sampling you
know we just have to involve many met
like let's say exponentially many
possible outputs that you can all
recognize you know rather than only one
or two outputs yeah I view this as a
major major challenge for the field you
know if you whether for boson sampling
for random circuit sampling whatever to
find such a protocol okay so now my last
thing that I wanted to mention is to
find actual applications of random
circuit sampling okay and you know in
until recently I think this would have
sounded like an oxymoron right like this
is a task that is almost specifically
designed to have no applications you
know which were except for disproving
guilt collage and you know and so forth
but a couple years ago I made an
observation which was
that you know once you can do random
circuit sampling you know in the way
that Google you know looks like it is
now done then you can almost immediately
take the experiment take the random
circuit sampling experiment and you can
repurpose it as a way to generate
cryptographically certified random bits
okay so so basically we're just looking
at you know this setup where this
Challenger sends a circuit to a quantum
computer the quantum computer quickly
sends back samples and and we're just
sort of looking at it from a different
lens and we're saying well you know the
the quantum computer has to quickly
respond with samples that pass this
linear cross-entropy benchmark right now
the original purpose of that was in
order for the quantum computer to prove
to the skeptic that it really is a
quantum computer right and you know and
then we think that this is a good test
for that but if the test passes then in
some sense you know it is proving
something else as a byproduct you know
or let me try to just convince you that
it least intuitively that this is true
even a quantum computer suppose that it
had to pass this linear cross entropy
benchmark but do so in a way that was
secretly deterministic okay how would it
do that right well you know it could
find the you know maybe the highest
probability output but the thing is we
don't expect that even a quantum
computer could efficiently do that okay
so you know intuitively it looks like
what the quantum computer would have to
do is sample the output you know now it
can play a few games here and there like
it could it could keep sampling until it
finds a string whose first bid is a one
you know so so it doesn't have to sample
from exactly the distribution we want
but you know no matter what it does it
seems like it has to sample from some
distribution that has a large entropy
okay and therefore if the test passes
then it could only have been passed by a
way that generates a lot of randomness
now you know by making some stronger
complexity theoretic assumption one can
justify what I
said one can say that if if it could do
it in a secretly deterministic way then
there would be some like AM protocols
that we don't think you know exist okay
but you know there are many many open
problems here you know related to can
you make this an actually practical
protocol right like you know the
verifier needs some randomness even to
generate the circuit you know can we
generate it pseudo randomly using a
small seed you know how why should
everyone else trust the verifier can we
get a decent bit rate out you know we
can get some random bits out but can we
get more can we get more and more random
bits by using the same circuit over and
over rather than by having to repeatedly
generate new circuits and finally what
other applications are there for you
know random circuit sampling there might
be other you know this could be used for
like proof of state crypto currencies
for example where you need a large
source of public randomness well you
know are there other cryptographic
applications where you know be a random
circuit sampling experiment where it's
sort of result you know prove something
cryptographically useful to you okay so
this is something that is really
exciting me right now as one of the main
possible applications for quantum
computers in the next decade let's say
alright and let me just leave you with
one kind of Zen question to you know
contemplate all right so I said that
quantum supremacy experiments are
basically the the complexity analog of
the Bell inequality okay so so how many
of you know charleston's inequality
right that says that quantum computers
cannot even you know even if even a
quantum mechanics you can you can only
violate the Bell inequality by so much
and by know more okay so what is the
complexity version of Terrell Sims
inequality you know can can't can a
quantum computer achieve a B value that
is greater than two if you've had a
magic box that could achieve B equals
three would that be computationally
useful would that let you solve any
problems that are outside of bqp or is
it very hard even for quantum computers
so let me just leave you with that
thought and thank you for listening
[Applause]